Transcriber: kamar Kharboutlly
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
نظمتنا ياسمين بشكل جيد، رجاءًا لنحييها.
(تصفيق)
أنا محمود عبد المجيد المواطن المتفائل .
يسألني الكثير من الناس
عندما يسمعون كلمة مواطن متفائل
“محمود،من الضروري أن تكون متفائلًا“.
فها أنت تعيش حياة جميلة، لديك سيارة جيدة،
تسافر وتجول حول العالم.
وهذا فعلًا ما أقوم به، لكنه ليس كل الحكاية
حكايتي لها بداية مختلفة.
تبدأ حكايتي منذ عام 1950،
أي منذ 70 عام تقريبًا
مع والدي ووالدتي .
وُلد والدي ووالدتي في حي فقير
اسمه حي كيت كات،
من حارة ضيقة اسمها حارة ابن يزيد.
كان جدي أبو والدي حدادًا،
يذهب كل يوم ليقطف رزقه
كان جدي لوالدتي  في رتبة صول
في الشرطة ويعمل سائقًا للحاكمدار.
لم تكن جدتاي من الناحيتين
تعرفان القراءة أو الكتابة.
لكنهما كانتا تؤكدان في تربية ابناءهما
على ضرورة بذل الجهد والتعب
لتطوير أنفسهم وتعليمها، حيث لا يوجد حل آخر
وكل ذلك  لرغبة الآباء والأمهات
أن يكون أولادهم أفضل حالًا منهم.
قيل لهم، “لا يوجد هناك حل، وبلغة البلد،
عليكم تعلّم سف التراب أي تناوله“.
وأصبح والدي ضابطًا ووالدتي مهندسة،
كانا جيرانًا،
وقعا في الحب وتزوجا،وعاشا في شقة مكونة
من غرفة وصالة تحت السلّم.
لقد كانت هذه هي البداية،
حيث استفادا من طريقة التفكير
التي تعلّماها من أهاليهما وظلا يفكران هكذا
وقالا علينا أن نتعلّم ونجتهد ونتعب،
ونعلّم هذا لأولادنا،
وفعلًا، قال والديّ لي ولأخوتي،
ليس هناك خيار آخر إلا التعليم والاجتهاد،
لذا إن أردتم أن تكونوا أفضل حالًا منّا،
وأن تحققوا ما تريدونه،
عليكم أن تعلموا وتجتهدوا، مرةً أخرى،
عليكم سف التراب أي تناوله.
أعرف أنها كلمة ثقيلة أي مهمة صعبة.
في عام 2001،
يوم تقديم العزاء بجدي اتذكر جيدا
كان والدي يضع يده على كتفي،
وهو يصافح أصحابه،
ويقول لهم، “هذا محمود ابني الصغير،
أرى أنا ووالدته أنه يتمتع بصفات
تجعله يحقق ما لم نستطع تحقيقه“.
عندها كنت في الثانوية العامة،
وكنتُ أعتقد أنه يقول ذلك حتى أدرس وأنجح.
لكن في الحقيقة، كان يقول لأنه
لا يرغب أن ينتهي إرث والده في يوم وفاته.
يريد أن يبقى إرث والده مع أولاده
وأحفاده وأحفاد أحفاده أيضًا.
وبصراحة، بالنسبة لي لم أتردد
وقمتُ بما عليّ القيام به؛
اجتهدت في الثانوية العامة،
وحصلتُ على مجموع جيد،
وطبعًا لأننا اليوم ننحدث عن المهندسن
فقد دخلتُ كلية الهندسة.
(ضحكات)
الجمهور: [غير مسموع]
(ضحكات). لا، لا، دعونا نترك ذلك، و ...
صراحةً، عملتُ بجد على تطوير نفسي
في الكلية وتخرجتُ بتفوق وتعينتُ للعمل.
تعينت في الجامعة وقالوا لي أنني مُجِد.
لكن للأمانة عندما تخرجت من الجامعة،
لم أكن متفائلًا جدًا بصراحة.
كان لدي حالة من التشاؤم،
حالة بأنني لا أقدرُ على تحقيق أي شيء،
حالة أنني لا أريد عمل شيء.
وعندما كان أحد ما يسألني ما الحل؟
أرد أن الحل في USA أي السفر إلى أمريكا،
أن أترك البلد وأمشي،
أن أفرُ وأذهب لدراسة الماجستير.
ولقد لعبت الأقدار معي لعبة غريبة،
فبعد سنة وجدت نفسي في طيّارة،
مسافر إلى أمريكا.
أتزوج، أعمل، أدرس الماجستير،
كل ذلك في آن واحد، هناك شيء مهم سيحدث.
لكن مثل ما يقولون ثقة عمياء بالنفس.
وذهبت الى أمريكا،
تعرفت على زوجتي، أحبك عزيزتي.
(ضحك وتصفيق)
ووجدت أن حياتي في ستتغير،
وسأتزوج وأبحث عن عمل.
وكنتُ كلما أقول لأي شخص أنني أريد أن أعمل،
كان يرد أنه بإمكاني العمل
في متجر أو في فرن،
وكنت أرد أنني مهندس،
وصدقوني بإمكاني العمل بتخصصي.
لا يجب عليك أن تتعب،
وأنا أفهم طريقة تفكير الأمريكيين.
المهم، بدأت في البحث على شركة قريبة
كانوا يريدون مطور برمجيات.
فقلت لهم لو سمحتم
اختبروني لمدة شهر مجانًا،
فأنا لا أريد مالًا،
فقط اختبروني فقد أستطيع الإنجاز.
فقالوا لي سنقوم بواجبنا معك،
ونمنحك فرصة تجريبية لمدة أسبوعين،
لكن لا تعتقد أننا نقوم بتعيينك،
نحن فقط نساعدك لكي تبدأ.
بعد خمسة أعوام، تركت هذه الشركة
وانا مدير التكنولوجيا فيها
(تصفيق وهتاف)
حصلت على درجة الماجستير،
وكانت تتألف دفعتي من 49 هنديًا وأنا.
الهنود مُجدّون جدًا جدًا.
حصلت على تقدير دراسي/ GPA
يعادل 4.0 وكنتُ الأول على دفعتي.
(تصفيق)
وتزوجتُ وحققت أشياء كثيرة
في أمريكا ونجاحات حمدًا لله!
لكن كان دائمًا لدي سؤال،
لماذا يوجد مطوّرون من الهند،
ولا يوجد مطوّرون من مصر؟
نعم!
وقررت في عام 2015 الرجوع إلى مصر،
وقال لي العديد من الناس،
أنت جئت أمريكا، فهل هناك أحد
يترك أمريكا ويعود إلى مصر؟
فأجبت أنني مقتنع أننا نستطيع
القيام بأي شيء في مصر.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
وعدتُ وقررتُ تأسيس شركة،
يعمل فيها المهندسون على تلزيم العمل بدلًا
من إنجازة في الهند، القيام به في مصر.
وبدأت بالتجول في مناطق مثل: إمبابة،
وأرض اللواء ودار السلام،
وكنتُ أجلس مع الشباب في المقهى
لأفهم طريقة تفكيرهم ومَن يريد العمل بجدية.
فلقد خضتُ التجربة وأدركتُ أننا
نستطيع الإنجاز وبدأت بولد وبنت.
وبعد خمس سنوات، أصبح الفريق المؤلف
من شخصين مكوّن من تسعة أشخاص،
وأنا أحدثكم الآن، لديّ عضو فريق
في سيليكون فالي في أمريكا
من أفضل 130 امرأة في العالم.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
قبل أربع سنوات، لم تكن تعرف
أي شيء في هذا المجال،
لكن بالتصميم وطريقة التفكير والاجتهاد
أي سف التراب استطاعت أن تكون موجودة الآن.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
لذلك، لا أريد من أحد أن يقول لي،
أننا لا نستطيع، لا نحن نستطيع.
اللاعب الأفضل عالميًا هو مصري،
بالرغم من ما يقولونه، فهو مصري؛
وقد تعلّم هنا في مصر، وسافر من هنا من مصر،
لذلك نحن نستطيع فعل كل شيء من هنا.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
الموضوع ليس سهلًا،
فلا تصدقون من يقول لكم أن الدنيا سهلة،
يقول ربنا في القرآن:
“لَقَدْ خَلَقْنَا الإنْسَانَ فِي كَبَدٍ“.
والكَبَد يعني المشقة،
يعني أصل الدنيا مشقة وتعب.
لكن يقول ربنا في القرآن أيضًا:
“إِنَّا لا نُضِيعُ أَجْرَ
مَنْ أَحْسَنَ عَمَلًا“.
ستحصد على قدر تعبك وجهدك.
(تصفيق الجمهور)
أنا متفائل لأجل هذا،
فهمتُ أن الحياة صعبة وأن الحياة اجتهاد،
وأنها تعطي بقدر ما نعطيها.
ستسألون، يا محمود حسنًا، ماذا نفعل؟
هناك أربع نقاط:
الأولى: احمدوا ربنا
على كل النِعم التي أنتم فيها
فلدينا نِعم كثيرة جدًا لكننا لا ندركها،
بما فيها كل النِعم الصغيرة
سأقول لكم معلومة صغيرة،
هناك 892 مليون إنسان
في العالم ليس لديه مرحاض.
المرحاض باعتبارة شيء مفروغ منه
عند معظمنا ونستخدمه يوميًا،
هناك 392 مليوم إنسان ليس لديه المرحاض.
الثانية: الصبر،
يحتاج التغيير إلى وقت،
لا يوجد شيء يحدث بسرعة.
الثالثة: التعليم والتعلّم والقراءة،
ليس هناك حلٌ إلا بالتعلّم،
لا أحد يتحسّن إلا عندما يتعلم.
أنتم أشخاص محظوظون جدًا وللغاية،
لأنكم ولدتم في هذا العصر.
أنتم تفتحون أجهزتهم المحمولة
وتكتبون نصًا على الشاشة،
يظهر لكم كل ما تبحثون عنه،
وكل ما تريدونه، فالتعليم فرصة ذهبية.
الرابعة: الشغف، لكن ليس الشغف لأي شيء؛
شغف للمجهود وشغف للعمل الشاق،
وللتعب وسف أو تناول التراب.
لو لديكم هذا الشغف،
ففي أي مجال أو أي شيء تختارونه
ستكون فيه مبدعين حقًا.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
هذا كل شيء، هذه حكايتي
أنا محمود عبد المجيد المواطن المتفائل
شكرًا لكم.
(تصفيق)